there's good news on the economic front
on Friday the Dow hit its eighth
consecutive record high at the same time
the Department of Labor released the
July jobs report showing an increase of
more than two hundred thousand jobs and
unemployment falling to a 16 year low
for more on this we turn to CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger Jill
good morning good morning
this is good news yeah yeah I'll take it
two hundred two hundred nine thousand
jobs created in July that means that our
monthly job creation for the first seven
months of the year is about let's call
it one hundred eighty five ish a month
right that's just behind last year's
pace and frankly a lot of economists are
very pleased by this because they say in
the ninth year of a recovery to be
creating a hundred eighty or 185
thousand jobs a month is fantastically
worthless we're running out of steam
here exactly and we saw some good
broad-based gains across different
sectors although not so much in
manufacturing and construction four
point three is the unemployment rate
what does that mean for us well I mean
look it is a 16 year lower tied with a
16 year low and it tells a story but not
the whole story because we also look at
another unemployment rate just to
confuse you it's a broader unemployment
rate it means I'm not I don't have a job
and I'm actively looking or I have a
part-time job and I want a full-time gig
so I'm sort of disgruntled right that
rate is 8.6 percent that is still above
where we were before the recession
started so not all hunky-dory on the
labor front just yet we're talking about
the labor participation rate yeah
another little annoying
it's a signal that leaves us more no
okay so this is a number of the people
have been making a lot of in the less
hopefully so you will hear people say we
people are out of the labor force what
does that mean right that's what this is
measuring it's saying who is in the
labor force who's actively looking for a
job this rate was up at about 66% before
the recession started now it's down to
around 63 percent that's near a 40-year
low what does that tell us
well about half of the drop is baby
boomers are retiring the other half
we're not so sure there are people who
are maybe not having the skill level
necessary in the current economy this is
what you hear from a lot of people who
are
industries that have been downsized so
we still have to pay attention to that
we had record highs for the Downs this
week what does that mean for us what
does that tell us well I think what it
tells you very clearly is companies are
making money and we're just at the end
of second quarter reporting season
company's earnings in the sp500 are up
nine percent from a year ago that
follows a 14 percent increase in the
first quarter that is very good news for
corporate America of course the stock
market is not the economy and about half
of Americans don't own a stock a mutual
fund or any any it means nothing to that
so they'd rather get a wage increase do
you think that we've been looking at for
quite a while it doesn't seem to be
moving too much is wage or wages yeah
just despite all this job growth we've
had what's happening with the wages so
wages up two and a half percent from a
year ago and you're absolutely right
that is a missing component here and the
reality is that with the labor market
tightening economists really thought we
were gonna see wage increases of closer
to three percent maybe more what is
happening is likely that in certain
areas we are seeing big wage gains right
you're a software engineer you're
getting a wage game but in other areas
it's dragging it down so the overall is
not so hot the only good news is
inflation is really low prices are up
only about 1.7 percent from a year ago
so if you got a two and a half percent
increase prices up by one percent 1.7
percent you should be okay you doing
okay overall a good report though
Schlessinger thanks so much